Speaker 1: There's such a packed program for
you today that there's really no time to waste.
For me telling you, this is a great show today.
We might record this one today.
We might actually save this one today because
the show is so packed that it would be a disservice
given the huge news I have to discuss with
you to spend time talking about the show in
a sort of meta sense.
And so I'm not going to do that.
I'm not going to talk about the show.
We're just going to do the show.
Okay.
And at the top, we have to talk about the
collapsing polling numbers for Democrats,
not only in the House, we knew the House was
probably lost, but also the Senate.
And there are a couple of different suspicions
I have about why this is happening.
Let's reset.
Historically, in general, one party wins the
White House first midterm.
It goes very poorly for that party.
Bill Clinton won the White House in 1992,
1994.
Historic defeat by Republicans in which Newt
Gingrich, Republican, comes to power as speaker
of the House and significantly moves the Republican
Party away from Reagan and towards Trump in
a story that we've told many times before.
An exception to this was in 2000 and 2002
George W Bush Republican winning in 2000 Republicans
actually doing okay in 2000.
Two considered extenuating circumstances lead
up to the Iraq war, post-9-11, etc..
But generally, we would expect Democrats to
do poorly in November.
That being said, it looked as though Democrats
were clearly going to keep control of the
Senate.
In fact, there was a close to 70% chance,
according to the FiveThirtyEight forecast,
that that indeed would happen.
That has changed.
The Senate at this point is basically a coin
flip.
It's a coin flip with like a slightly heavier
head side.
So it's like 55, 45 that in fact, those are
the exact numbers right now.
If you look at the FiveThirtyEight forecast,
it is a 45% chance that Republicans take the
Senate.
55% chance that Democrats win.
And if you scroll down the FiveThirtyEight
forecast page, which we are linking to, you
see the change.
You see how the forecast has changed.
And you see that after peaking right above
70% odds for Democrats in mid-September, it
has been a slow collapse and then a rapid
collapse all the way to what is now basically
a coin flip.
Now, if we look at the House, Democrats were
never favored to keep the House, but it didn't
look this grim.
And unfortunately, the range now of outcomes
is with Republicans just barely taking the
House by one seat all the way to Republicans
holding a nearly 40 seat majority, Democrats
now have a 19% chance of holding the House.
And if you look at how those numbers have
changed over time, sorry.
Here, here it is.
You also see that there was a similar inflection
point, at which point it became a sort of
2 to 1 disadvantage for Democrats in late
September.
It is now down to a one in five shot for Democrats.
Adding on to the not particularly good news,
a court has temporarily blocked Joe Biden's
student loan forgiveness, which was one of
the actions that Joe Biden took, which was
bullying Democrats and improving odds for
November.
So what is going on here?
There's basically two major stories here that
I would point to.
Number one, it is absolutely the case that
when the Supreme Court overturned Roe v Wade,
given that Americans support Roe v Wade by
a greater margin than at any point in the
Roe v Wade era, that there was anger.
There was anger from men, there was anger
from women.
There was there was anger about that decision
because it is, after all, a right wing activist
Supreme Court at this time.
And there was renewed interest in voting and
there was energy behind, listen, if this is
what these Republicans are going to do, we've
got to elect some Democrats.
The timing of that energy seems to be dissipating.
And when you now ask people what are the most
important issues, they say economy and they
say inflation, etc..
So the analogy I used over the weekend on
a livestream was if you are getting ready
for, you know, a big test at school and you
say, I'm going to I'm going to have a quadruple
express espresso, I almost said the thing.
Express right now I'm going to have a quadruple
espresso and I'm going to be all fired up
and ready to go.
And you take the espresso too early and your
energy peaks an hour before the test.
And then by the time the test starts, the
espressos wearing off, you've mistimed the
surge of energy.
And that is.
The analogy to what I think happened here
with Roe v Wade.
Now, the timing wasn't up to us.
The Supreme Court had its timing.
And I believe that that is one fact, one factor.
The other side is that Democratic messaging
has not been very good.
And later, we're going to look at a clip from
Gavin Newsom, who says the most dangerous
states by by crime rates are all red states.
And yet we let Republicans take over the narrative
and say violent Democrat states, violent Democrat
state.
That's just one example.
But I do think the messaging from Democrats
has continued to be terrible and the messaging
from Republicans is continue to be effective.
So those are two major factors.
It's really not looking good.
Do we give up?
Of course not.
I mean, listen, if you live in Pennsylvania,
you get to vote for the Senate, you get to
vote for the governor and other local races.
You might as well do it.
And then we see what happens.
But the numbers overall from a 30,000 foot
standpoint are looking increasingly bad for
Democrats, and that is very bad for the country
because of the delusional, extreme nature
of the modern Republican Party.
And by the way, they're also starting to intimidate
voters.
Let's talk about that next.